i love the show billions you know i've
been all over it i have my axe capital
mug here oh yeah where did you get it so
i can have it from for this interview
would you mind just fetching it i'm
sorry i just didn't have it i can't get
up and do this i just need to get in the
moment i have an axe capital mug i've
got my axe cap um
zip up vest that'll walk around town
people will be like where the hell did
you get that from it's like too bad i
know kopplin i know people i know the
people who have created it i know the
writers of it and you know i've been
the words for it is caping right i've
been using that phrase all day i've been
taping for the show for some time and i
cannot be more excited that season five
is resuming this sunday on show time 8
p.m uh 9 p.m eastern time and one of the
best on that program and everything that
he does plays the role of mike
wagswagner
is the actor david costable back here in
the rich eisen show how you been david
i'm well how are you i'm psyched to see
what you've got cooked up i'm so excited
got some good stuff now what what is
caping
caping is the phrase it's kind of like
you know you're you're you're backing
somebody's play you're it's like you're
superman you're putting on the cape and
you're and you're trying to
uh be there for them so i'm caping for
you that's the phrase nice you clearly
are have you you are you you are
superman
well
i appreciate that
and just the fact that i got to actually
spend a day on the set with you and the
rest of the crew a couple of years ago
is truly uh like a career highlight for
me
david it was so fantastic as well for me
i'll tell you that right now now you
have an axe capital mug but you do not
have a uh what would wags do t-shirt
oh boy you're about to get four sizes
is it really what would wags do t-shirt
you have not been you've been up and
doing your merchandise homework my
friend there's a cutout of wags that you
can purchase for yourself i mean i'm
sure that we could have somebody
you know for a keeper such as you i'm
sure that we could have someone get you
one yep well i got to tell you david um
i i kind of assume what wags would do
about anything and it's not anything
that i would normally be a default for
me you know i think that that is i think
that is probably true for me as well
how do you i actually then have to go
and do it which is even frankly even
more fun that is uh my question for you
is is who do you channel
when you take on this roll of wags on
billions where scruples are kind of
thrown out the window 99 times out of
100 oh rich
you've you you've been you've been to
new york city have you you've lived in
new york city you served in new york
city yes sir so
i think that there is um
i think there's a modicum of rage that
uh we all can become
uh
filled by some days when we live in new
york city and i feel like you know i
have a lot of access to that particular
aspect of
living
and um it just is uh i and now i get to
foster it inside of myself in this
particular way and so you know that that
and that not only that can release in
many different ways and for wags he
likes to enjoy the full rainbow of rage
release possibilities
what's the your favorite wags line that
you're able to say on this show right
now i don't think there is i think there
is
there has definitely been stuff that
i've i've just looked back like seen
like clips of them and in the second
third seasons i was like my gosh
i can't believe i said that that's
appalling
terrible terrible thing to say so then
what's the most enjoyable uh part of
playing this role
david for you i mean
i i you know there is nobody who has
more
first of all more fun on the set than me
um i get to say absolutely the best
lines that those guys write um they get
to enjoy writing they get to i think i
think one of the things about the
writers too and this has been seasoned
after season is that they like to
surprise themselves with how appalling
they can be with regard to the flags um
there have definitely been times when in
that you know
okay
the one time in a week that we
um per episode we would all be together
and we would do a table we would read
the whole thing yes and there are just
some times where the i would say
something and i would just you know the
thing that people do on the the when
people are throwing free throws or
shooting free throws yeah they're
they're holding their shorts at the
knees yeah it just sort of crumples you
with the mid section you got to hold on
to your shorts in order to
stay up
i love it so that's it that's the best
that is absolutely the best part when i
can either crumple myself or they
crumple me or yes i crumple the rest of
the company it's a spectacular feeling
sometimes though when a player pulls on
their shorts it's because they've got to
catch their breath i imagine it's the
same thing with you too with that
character you know i mean it is so great
well what what uh if anything david
constable here on the rich eyes and show
showtime billions coming back for season
five
what can you tell us about the future of
this show um how many how many more
seasons anything that you've got that
you know you have inside information you
should definitely do some you should see
if you can get go to like a showtime
executive meeting okay if you can find
out the answer to that that would be
fantastic so uh we're now we we finished
the fifth season yes and um we went
straight into the sixth season terrific
so there will be we will have shot by
december we will have shot uh
17 new episodes of billions geez um
wow so there will be there will be lots
of billions coming at you and there is
some truly appalling things that i say
that well i would i do not disappoint
this season and next frankly well i got
to tell you the the
you're the only person on the show whose
character can even approach yours um in
terms of appalling and you never know
what comes out of their mouths
is uh the father of paul giamatti on the
program uh charles just a month
unbelievable yeah and chuck rhodes dad
um you know on this show um and do you
ever like have a go pull him aside have
a chuckle over some of the stuff that
comes out of your mouth and and share a
moment like that sort of thing
to me like i want to be that actor when
i grow up because i feel like he's he's
such a spectacular actor and and
and everything that they write for him
makes me laugh and he is he's just it's
it's remarkable to watch him do it he's
just
he's absolutely he's brilliant he's
brilliant at it and he he also i feel
like he gets to lean into things that um
none of the rest of us ever would do and
there is there i was
they they screamed um for us the other
day the the eighth episode which is the
the next episode that's going to be on
september 5th sunday that's right uh our
premiere and there is a particular scene
that when i read it on the page it just
you because you know what he's going to
do and you know how awesome it's going
to be and he
truly does not ever disappoint okay
that's uh that's i i can't wait for
sunday night again uh 9 eastern on
showtime the resumption of season five
of billions david costable here on the
rich eisen show i i said it to you when
i met you and you've been on the show
before i mean the shows that you have
been on david
uh damages the wire breaking bad and now
this one is there a common thread do you
think between the shows as to why
they're successful or
uh anything um that you think that is a
common thread amongst any of these
programs i mean the common thread is
david constable i think
outside of the obvious yes there's
another actor who was on all of um i
come to think that there isn't one
that's just me no just oh
that's right i don't know i guess but
that's just the gold standard once once
constable shows up then you're just like
oh the golden age of television is alive
by the way let me tell you something
dave david
you've come to the right place in terms
of tooting your own horn and also and
also going third person while doing it
we respect that sir we salute that here
on the rich eisen show
yeah i mean you haven't you have your
own
television you have in your show yeah
you you get through
to refer to yourself all of the time oh
yes as rich isaac yeah as a matter of
fact you know i i i uh just to show how
much i respect you and your show i i
removed the rich eyes and show mug for
the axe cat mug i mean i don't do that
for just anybody or any show
you know
yeah no why would you for god's sake
we're i'm on your show
not you're not online anymore what's in
what's the name of the show again i
forgot what the name of the show is one
more time here uh i think we've got a
reminder there it is hold on this is the
rich eisen show even they've got that
reminder just for anybody who needs it
do you have like a button on your belt
that you can just press that when you're
just like this is the rich eisen show no
it's a good idea it's just it's it's
just it just senses whenever it's
necessary it's the guy he pays billions
that's right yeah yeah yeah i pay you
billions mike that's for sure uh all
right so screw that question um so let
me ask you then uh
when you showed up on the set of
breaking bad uh it was
it was which season how did you wind up
on breaking bad
well i had i had been a fan of it and i
had a very good clip good friend of mine
was one of the writers on it
um his name is sam catlin and um
sam did not get me the job
not and un surprisingly and i was like
wow you really didn't but one of the
other producers that actually suggested
me and i went and auditioned
um then they spent i think six long
weeks looking for anybody but me to play
the role um they luckily did not find
anybody but me so i had to go and do it
which was great
and um
often you know either either this you
you haven't been on the show or the show
it's it's just starting so you don't
know but and this one i had been like a
a fan and i was like a kooky fan already
and that was back then you know in the
the first and second season it was not
as popular with television program as it
turned out to be in the end um so it was
a smaller it was a smaller culty piece
so i got there and um i was very very
excited to do the role because i also i
loved it and i loved the writing the
writing was incredible and that was just
so um so i get there and i had to play
and the very first day that i was
shooting was with brian
we're meeting in this lab and it's this
brand new giant set that they hadn't
shot before and they're using my
character and this big set they're going
to use for a long time and
um it was a big whoop to do today and so
i'm you know trying to play it cool and
at a after about maybe two hours of you
know we've been doing the scene and
we're doing another part of the scene
and brian and i eventually are just
sitting right next to each other in our
little cast chairs and
having a coffee or something and
and i and i finally started to disclose
how much i loved the show
and then i didn't really stop myself
from
telling him in very very detailed terms
what how much i loved him
and he you could just see it on his face
because eventually it got to the point
of be like and then in episode 12 and
season two and what you did in this one
moment when you lit you didn't raise
your eyebrow but then you looked at her
uh and and he just kind of looked at me
and just started slowly backing away
from oh god and he's like
and i was like oh no oh no
i've got i've gone super fan on him he
thinks i'm a total imposter this is
terrible i'm gonna get fired off the
show that i just started
um but luckily he just he he let me have
a breather and and uh i cool down after
that
he's such a good dude though he probably
he probably you know i mean he's such a
good dude he's like a great human
american exactly so he must have taken
his chart i have a similar story to that
i'll share with you is when i met bob
barker okay
now in terms of in terms of game show
hosts i would say he's the brian
cranston in many ways a game show host
yeah i mean absolutely he's great all
time great so i i went up to him uh
because i'm a die-hard prices right guy
in college and growing up whatever so i
went around up to him david and i said
to him you know hey uh boy i i just want
to take the time i'm sure you've heard
this before
but i have a different perspective of
why i love you that i'm i'm a host on
nfl network
and you know i i interview players from
all walks of life rookies and folks who
are retired hall of famers and not so
great players and people from different
backgrounds and i am inspired about
welcoming them all in the same way that
you've welcomed people to contestants
row no matter their background or
socioeconomic status or race color creed
you just welcome all of them the same
way and i just wanted to say you've
inspired me and thank you
and he looks at me you know what he says
to me
he says to me he says to me do you want
to hug it out
oh come on the only answer to that is
yes that's what i said i said yes after
that as a matter of fact i do want to
hug it out yes bob barker i want to hug
you
100
i did and it was one of the greatest
answers that i could have gotten from
him
you know it's like do you want to hug it
out and we did in fact hug it out wow i
got to do that that is strong because
i'm the same way
david i'm the same way if i meet
somebody who i'm a fan of i will tell
them that you know and you should you
know go ahead you know why not that's
the way i always felt i've told i've
told you when i met you how excited i
was to meet you that i've spent
countless countless hours listening to
you talk about sports well like really
just too many hours
just late into the night just like i
really should be not listening to this
person
and make pithy comments with his friends
on the television set but yeah i was and
i did it and you did it and and now
you're telling me and i loved it i loved
it do you want to hug it out
yeah if i was there i would 100 crawl
over that desk and give you a hug
100
and it was just like you know when i i
met you and i i i definitely did fanboy
you too and uh i told the story just a
few minutes ago and uh i had you take a
selfie with me and you took a smiling
one with me and it was very nice and i
looked down at my phone i thought to
myself i got to take this opportunity
i'm like now would you mind giving me
one of his wags and
and you flip the camera off and it's
just that's my therapist we're putting
it up on the screen we're blowing it out
but it's just you know yeah that's the
real one that's the real life
that's the real that that's the real
selfie
not a lot of people get that one but
you're a special person
at least at least i'm not going to blur
it out and put it on national television
and radio at least it won't do that
i cannot wait what you've got planned uh
sir i can't wait to see it i will be
tuned in on sunday night i cannot wait
and everybody should catch up on
billions if you already haven't uh in
advance of the return of season five
nine pm eastern on show time sunday
night thanks for the time david i
appreciate it great talking to you right
back at you that is david constable
right here on the rich eisen show at
david underscores costable on instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here